so 500 years ago Galileo said that the
book of nature is written in a language
of mathematics and this really turned
out to be true for for physics it was
really incredibly powerful in
understanding physical phenomena and for
some strange reason and it really nobody
understands it just turned out to be not
very powerful at describing biological
phenomenon and in fact we have a lot of
mathematical tools now we use to
understand biological phenomena in in in
general but but we have not been
successful in finding serve a universal
language and I think that our study
really adds to a growing body of
evidence that the language of the brain
is statistics that the brain operates as
a statistical engine it's not a logical
engine based on reason but a statistical
engine based on evidence and if you
think about it your legs couldn't tell
you
Newton's laws but they still obey them
and of course your brain
might not be able to explain the laws of
statistics but it's still based on
so I don't believe there's any
theoretical reason why our brain cannot
be simulated in a computer the problem
is right now that we have a hundred
billion neurons in the brain perhaps
fewer if you count some relevant ones in
the neocortex and we don't understand
how they're connected we don't
understand the tricks of the
architecture and we don't fully
understand and how what are the route
what's relevant about it that we need to
simulate but what we understand already
that the piecemeal is that there's
nothing mysterious that needs to be
added so small and small scale when we
ask the question a smaller scale not can
you simulate the brain but can you
simulate a particular process we're
getting better and better at it and
better and better at accounting for for
how our brain functions